today's drew gooder is serena jones
from miami florida who's making
headlines for her
organization village fridge and she came
up with a unique way to provide
free meals to miami locals who have been
struggling through the pandemic
and uh sharina is here now i can't wait
to meet her hello
hi drew thank you so much for having me
oh my gosh serena you're so beautiful
inside and out thank you
i was so excited about this story
because when the pandemic first started
it was one of the things that i
gravitated to
most was community fridges and yours is
very special
please tell us about it and when it
started
village fridges was founded in august of
2020
the word fridge is a combination of the
word fridge and free
i wanted to combat the growing hunger
crisis in the community because the
pandemic had taken a toll on
so many families so i just sat day and
night like what could i do
to help so i took 180 of my own money
and i purchased the first community
refrigerator and i got with business
owners my cousin isaiah thomas and danny
agnew of roots collective and i asked
them
would they mind if i put a refrigerator
outside of their
business and they agreed to do so so
that's how this amazing initiative
started
with two guys that agreed to put the
refrigerator outside their business
and you also have a small business that
was impacted by the pandemic right
yes i am a full-time esthetician at snob
beauty box which is my baby that i
birthed
eight years ago so i um do beauty
services on women
eyelashes makeup skincare and body
waxing
so in my remaining time outside of
running my
full-time entrepreneurship job
i take care of the community
refrigerators
i mean while so many of us
want to try to figure out what we can do
you are out there
doing it what do you try to put in your
fridges may i ask
inside the refrigerators we make sure we
include water canned goods sandwiches
bread potatoes
frozen foods that can be microwaved
and we just don't accept anything that's
opened i have eat it and always be sure
to check the dates of things that are
donated to the fridge
i mean it just seems like in everything
you do whether it's your beautiful
business as an esthetician or
building your community fridges you are
such a caretaker
and so thoughtful and thorough about
everything you're saying
and true-gooders like you are just so
important to us here at the show but far
more importantly
the communities that they serve and we
just wanted to tell you that our friends
at
omaha steaks heard about what you're
doing
and they want to send you 10 000
worth of single-serve protein meals and
steak snacks
[Applause]
thank you so much
serena you are such an inspiration i
really mean it when we
sit there and we think about all the
things we can do
i think the acting on it is the big
difference and
the way that you follow through the
example that you set
and the service and goodness and
life-changing health that you provide
people
we're just in awe of you here really
thank you
thank you so much for having me thank
you to sharina okay
so for more information on how you can
help support the gofundme for village
fridge friege visit our website
and um we'd love to drive as much
support as we can to you serena
thank you for everything you're doing
[Music]